Yoplait Anna
capital of Slovenia population 280,000
it's known for its well-preserved old
town magnificent buildings everywhere
many of them centuries old one of them
houses the Municipal Museum spell avid
ethnic and Rocco man of the ofis
architectural firm were contracted to
remodel the building and modernize it an
epic undertaking
archeologists on the site found several
pieces from Roman and medieval times
after six years of construction the
museum opened in 2004 so we're not here
in one of your first important buildings
what kind of feeling is it for you to
come back here to a museum actually for
me it's very nice because this is one of
the few museums in the city that is
really alive it's maybe because it's
also located in really in the heart of
the old city it has events actually
basically every day since the country
gained its independence from Yugoslavia
many of Luciano's old buildings have
been restored and countless new shops
have opened such as this one offering
unusual salt products Slovenia is known
for some of the highest quality salts in
the world and a friend of the two
architects designed this glass jar ofis
has also profited from the boom in new
construction here beloved edge Nick and
Rocco Mon have designed much of it from
public housing to luxury apartments in
the old town here two of the architects
preserved historical details such as
these pillars integrating them with
modern glass elements ofis is following
in illustrious footsteps the star
architect Jewish a pledge Nick for
example had designed the national
library
the triple bridges a group of three
bridges and the market hall he can be
inspiration especially to help something
which is unique which is you know which
all artists architects is gaining and
tried to be really original and creative
this time we set out for ofis
headquarters following the river loopy
and Itza
the offices are located on the top floor
of an older building we've met the
architects here before together we take
a look at our last report from 2011 back
then Baudette Nick and Oman showed us
various examples of their award-winning
work for example this Chapel which was
voted slovenia's church building of the
year in 2009 the architects were also
planning a stadium in Belarus and a
student housing building in Paris a lot
has happened in the last two years we
had our first opening of the bigger
building abroad which is in Paris in
January the mayor of Paris opened our
student housing it's almost two hundred
apartments which is actually a very good
success and then this year is also the
opening of the football stadium in
Belarus after the financial crisis hit
Slovenia the two had to put several
projects there on ice and ofis has since
been concentrating on building more
abroad in Oman the architects are
planning a huge shopping hotel and
Leisure Centre
while vedettes Nick picks up her
children we continue on with Rock'em on
the architect wants to show me a special
store the trash the knitwear
manufacturer has made a name for itself
abroad as well as at home even stars
like us actress Andie MacDowell wear the
label the last stop of the day with the
dets Nick and her three children we take
the cog railway up to the castle
there's a magnificent view of the city
from here but that's not the only reason
we've come
the architects want to show me one of
their favorite restaurants
the Strela CH serves food that's typical
of the region spell a village snake and
rock AMA love their home city serene
safe beautiful
Liana